- Plazas you see outside
of tall office buildings.
- All right, Margret Leigh
has got a backpack over here.
I'm gonna hide it in my jacket,
which has a hole in it,
and I'm also wearing my black power fist
so we'll see if we get
into the Trump Tower.
Nervous?
- A little.
- [Ciara] Yeah?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Ciara] All right, here we go.
- [Margaret] I mean, clearly
we're not the only ones
who got in.
Okay, we gotta get in the fifth one, so.
- All right, maybe the fifth
one is more, more exclusive?
- [Ciara] What the fuck?
Where the fuck is all the water?
- It's like an inventory
of everything that's here.
Look, we're doing our job.
- [Ciara] It's pretty efficient.
- It is.
Nine large trees.
Four small trees.
148 seats total.
64 fixed seats.
84 movable chairs.
21 tables.
- [Ciara] Should be count the chairs?
- [Margaret] Yeah, we should.
I mean I'm not gonna count them.
64.
I don't want to count them on each floor.
Um, some stores, high end stores.
Street, I mean I'm straining here.
- I feel like, I feel like if Donald Trump
were to have a garden this
is what it would look like.
This is pretty appropriate.
This is how I imagined it.
It's clean.
- What the reporter,
Aaron Elstein was saying
it's like kind of a missed
business opportunity,
'cause like you have this space.
You have 50 people up here.
And they could potentially put a cafe
and attract a lot more
tourists and customers.
And there's nothing up here.
- I felt, it's not like I felt unwanted,
but neither wanted either.
- There really wasn't any
sort of stumbling block
coming in.
- I feel dirty for doin' it.
- [Margaret] That fits you pretty well.